more than 15 million Americans are under
winter weather alerts this morning as
the tail end of a massive system sweeps
through the Northeast the storm started
in the Pacific Northwest four days ago
in brought snow sleet and freezing rain
from coast to coast
it caused accidents Airport delays power
outages and at least two deaths David
Pegg no is in Lake George New York that
is right in the storm's path David good
morning Nora good morning welcome to
Lake George we are about halfway between
Manhattan and Montreal Canada there's
nothing unusual about snow this time of
the year it's the middle of winter what
is unusual though is that a lot of the
major US cities have seen far less snow
this season than what they usually do at
this time in the winter but that doesn't
mean it's been any less miserable this
winter whiteout stretched from Wisconsin
to Massachusetts snow sleet and freezing
rain left behind a dangerous icy mess
trying to drive in these conditions felt
like mission impossible for drivers in
Massachusetts it has been accidents
everywhere in Indiana freezing rain
covered everything in a heavy ice
bringing down trees onto power lines ice
coated cars and roads in Chicago where
pedestrians had to watch out for sheets
of ice falling from skyscrapers the
heavy rain even triggered landslides
that shut down part of a Cincinnati
highway when we arrived in Saratoga
Springs New York the wet snow and slick
streets had kept some people off the
road all together I do drive but I am
avoiding driving today in Minnesota
alone over a 10 hour span State Police
responded to 179 crashes and more than
300 spinouts the storm dumped nearly a
foot of snow in parts of the Midwest and
an additional foot is expected in
Wisconsin and Michigan today varying
folks already trying to dig out this
neighborhood in st. Paul Minnesota was
left unplowed and that frustrated people
like crystal beter who needed help
getting her car out of the road it's
been a struggle I winter when it gets
like this we hear you crystal you know
last year was really snowy in the East
now it's been a reversed a lot of snow
out west in Seattle not as much on the
East Coast but John this morning the
award for the most snowfall goes to
Caribou Maine they've had a hundred and
fifteen inches that's about 10 feet of
No and they're expected to get another
foot today my goodness thank you David
that is no Louisiana riverboat behind
you it's cold up there for a Louisiana
boy thank you David